GOOD MORNING. THE RULES
COMMITTEE FOR THURSDAY MAY
SEVENTEENTH CONCERT BY COURT
ORDER. OF PC ADVICE ON AUDIO AND
VIDEO RECORDING OF TODAY'S
PROCEEDINGS BEHIND ME NESTLES
TELEVISED. AMENDED SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL COOLEY HERE
CUNNINGHAM HERE CARILLO HERE
CERVANTES HERE FRIEDMAN
GALLAGHER.
GRAYSON. MASTER.
NAZARIAN PRESENT SALAS PRESENT
WALDRON.
WE HAVE A QUORUM AND WE HAVE A
CONSENT AGENDA. IS OUR MOTION ON
THE CONSENT AGENDA MOVES. OVER
CELLS SEGMENT FARMERS CERVANTES
PATTERSON TURNED HIS CALL THE
ROLL COOLEY AYE COOLEY AYE
CUNNINGHAM AYE CUNNINGHAM AYE
CARILLO AYE CARILLO AYE
CERVANTES AYE CERVANTES AYE
FRIEDMAN GALLAGHER. GRAYSON AYE
GRAYSON AYE MAYES TIME MAYES AYE
KNOWS AREA I'VE NAZARIAN AYE
SALAS. SALAS AYE WALDRON MUCH.
THE MOTION PASSED AND THIS FLOWS
PARTISANSHIP